1000 troops on higher redness
including substantial air enabled combat
power
I expect leadership and tools a defense
production action plan to aggregate
demand boost capacity and increase
interoperability
to do all of this we need to invest more
at the summit allies would set them more
ambitious defense investment pledge to
invest a minimum of two percent of gross
domestic product annually on defense
today we are releasing new defense
spending estimates
in 2023 there will be a re- increase of
8.3 percent across European allies and
Canada
this is the biggest increase in decades
and then ninth consecutive year or
increases in our defense spending
so European allies on Canada will have
invested over
450 billion extra US dollars since we
agreed our defense investment pledge in
2014.
then only three allies spent two percent
of GDP on defense
this year 11 allies breached or exceed
the target
and we expect this number will rise
substantially next year
at the summit we will be joined by the
leaders of Australia New Zealand Japan
and South Korea
because our security is not Regional it
is global
so I work and work closely on issues
such as cyber security Maritime security
and new technologies
we'll also welcome the European Union to
villas
our partnership has reached
unprecedented levels and we are
committed to doing even more together
this will be finland's first summit
answer NATO Ally and we look forward to
Sweden joining as soon as possible
yesterday I hosted a constructive
meeting of senior officials of tortilla
Sweden and Finland
and as the next step I will need to
present the other one and prime minister
Sean in vilmuse on Monday afternoon
for almost 75 years NATO has been the
strongest Alliance in history
the decisions we will take at the
Village Summit will ensure we continue
to protect our people and our values
with that I'm ready to take your
questions
Lithuania National radio and television
thank you for this opportunity I have
two questions the first one is Ukraine
is called in 2008 Bucharest declaration
a historic mistake how business
declaration will be different from that
because in 2008 the leader said that
Ukraine will become a NATO member it and
it seems that you're going to repeat
this in 2023 so what's the difference
and the other question is have you got
heard something from president zielinski
will he participate in the Senate thank
you
um
there are many differences one important
difference is of course that Ukraine has
come much closer to Nato because NATO
allies have worked closely with Ukraine
for many years especially since 2014.
so this has ensured a much higher level
of cooperation and interoperability
between Ukraine and NATO and we also
I expect also that leaders when they
meet in Village they also agree a
package that will have to move Ukraine
even closer to Nato partly by
establishing the NATO Ukraine Council
which is a political platform where we
can have crisis consultations and also
actually make decisions together and
deepen our political cooperation
the Practical support
and not least the multi-a program also
has a clear political Dimension because
by agreeing to stand by Ukraine and also
help them for a longer term and to
ensure full interoperability with NATO
we are helping Ukraine to come even
closer to Nato and and NATO membership
and then finally I am confident that
we'll find the United Way also to
address the specific issue on
on membership but I will not go into the
details or exact language now because
that is something we will announce when
everything is in place by the sermon I
look forward to uh to welcoming uh
president Selinsky at the summit and and
to have him taking party in the first or
the inaugural meeting of the NATO
Ukraine Council
today
thank you very much from cgfgmtv Mr
stoltenberg first question would be the
US is actively considering it says to
send a class dominations to Ukraine
which are banned from more than 120
States
from a military point of view do you
think this is a good idea does Ukraine
need such a munitions and from a
political point of view do you think
it's wise to send weapons Munitions that
are banned for good reasons
Alliance do not have a position on the
convention on class termination because
a number of allies have signed the
convention but a number of allies have
not signed the convention
and it is for individual allies to make
decisions on the delivery of weapons and
Military supplies to Ukraine
and
so this will be for governments to
decide and not for NATO as an alliance
we are faced with a brutal war and um
and we have to remember that
this brutality is also reflecting the
fact that we every day see casualties
and that uh
close to missions is used by both
sides or closed missions are used by
both sides
and Russia used custom nations
in their brutal War aggression to invade
another country while Ukraine is using
it to defend itself
the best way to end this brutal war is
for President Putin and Russia to stop
attacking another country that was the
the best way to stop all the suffering
the casualties
and the death we see caused by the
different types of weapons on the
battlefield every day
MTV
secretaries
the meeting of yesterday with regards
Sweden was rather a kind of Icebreaker
between the Turkish side and the Swedish
said you said that it was constructed
however when we see the statement of the
Turkish minister Foreign Affairs and the
his Swedish counterpart
they are still a gap so how would you be
able to bridge that Gap until uh next
Monday and what kind of pressure because
you also call always object but what
kind of pressure you could do on Sweden
so that they somehow try to face or at
least release the concerns of turkey
thank you very much
um for me I think uh words like
constructive and good is better than
Icebreaker if I want to describe the
meeting we had yesterday it was a good
meeting it was a constructive meeting
and we made progress
and uh I'm confident that we'll continue
to make a progress but there are still
gaps to be bridged and that's also the
reason why
um I have invited the
president erdogan and um and prime
minister Christian to meet uh
next month on Monday also in few days in
village and we will meet there together
in the three hours with our experts to
sit down and look into the details the
concrete issues and where we see
differences between the Swedish position
and the position of turkey and then
that's the way to overcome differences
when they exist as they now do in the
issue related to
the final ratification of of 3D
succession into into NATO
um
my message is that
Sweden has delivered at the same time on
the commitments they made in Madrid in
the joint memorandum at the same time
I'm also very clear that
turkey has a
really security concerns and that's the
reason why we are sitting down and
addressing them
because we also know that NATO allies
have a serious security concerns related
to the fact that they want to have
Sweden in us as a full member as soon as
possible and that's not least the case
for the Baltic countries that see the
great advantage of having having Sweden
as a member so I strongly believe it
will be good for swim it will be good
for the Baltic region the Nordic region
and it will be also good for the whole
Alliance including turkey to have as
soon as member as soon as as possible
regarding declaration I don't understand
you can't comment on the language which
will be in the Declaration regarding
membership but can you tell us how far
or how close Alliance are regarding
averting in the Declaration regarding a
possible membership for Ukraine which
also will be satisfactory for cleave
thank you
so we are as we always are a head of a
NATO Summit now Consulting and working
on the exact language that's the way
NATO makes decisions we are 31 allies
and also of course uh having close
contacts with uh Ukraine uh but but
allies are now Consulting on the exact
language in the in the communique
um I'm confident that we will finally
United A Way Forward including on how uh
to to move Ukraine forward on its goal
to become a member of the the alliance
um I also expect as I said that there
will be
decisions on concrete support practical
support but that has a dimension also
when it comes to the political aspects
because more interoperability a
multi-air program for interoperability
between native forces and Ukraine forces
helps of course Ukraine to move towards
NATO and stronger political ties with
the native Ukraine Council it's also a
way to move Ukraine and NATO even closer
so the the language the exact wording
will be made public when
we have read and when the statement is
endorsed by all the leaders next week
but I'm confident that we'll have a
message which is clear and also not only
clear but but that but most of all that
we have to remember that allies also
agree already on a lot of important
principles when it comes to Ukraine and
membership we agree that NATO store is
open uh we we agree that that Ukraine
will become a member which is an
important message and then we agree that
it's uh for the NATO allies and and
Ukraine to decide when the time is right
and not for Russia to have a veto and
then the most urgent task and all unless
we are not is that we will stand by
Ukraine we will provide support for the
Ukraine for as long as it takes Because
unless Ukraine win this war there's no
no membership issue to be discussed at
all and that's the reason why allies are
stepping by providing donations Military
Support uh
thank you for the question we continue
to hear please from uh Ukraine for
allies to send more artillery ammunition
are you satisfied with what allies have
sent and the state of their defense
production
so NATO allies are sending and have sent
uh unpleasant levels of ammunition many
different types of ammunition and
they're continuing to make new
announcements uh new donations and all
of this is coordinated uh in a very good
way and and and that's also the reason
why the ukrainians have been able to
retake land in the north and east and
the South are now so weeks ago they're
able to launch the offensive and the
offensive
um is moving forward they are able to uh
to liberate land then of course there's
a very high rate of consumption of
ammunition in in the meat operations
which are going on now thousands of
Channel shells every day so it's an
enormous need to resupply and that's
exactly what the Allies are doing there
are resupplying constantly Ukraine with
more ammunition spare parts maintenance
for the different artillery systems
armored
vehicles battle times air defenses and
and so on and and and that need will
continue to be there and therefore we
need continued uh support and continued
uh decision-making
the strength in the NATO Allied
countries to to make further decisions
on uh even more support so that's that's
uh that
because on production well what we have
seen is that since we started to address
this issue of the need to increase our
production capacity last fall then
things have started to to to move so now
more and more allies are actually
signing contracts the things that can
actually increase production is of
course
contracts with the industry we engaged
with the industry at our latest defense
ministerial meeting
we have also
worked on a defense production action
plan which I expect the Allied Leaders
to agree on both how to aggregate demand
how to make sure that we are buying
things together joint procurement is the
way to to get off the numbers and
therefore reduce the the cost to utilize
the economy of scale we have done joint
procurement in nature for many many
years we have the NATO support
recruitment agency which is now actually
facilitating several big projects also
for back to the size of ammunition we
have increased the guidelines for how
much better the size of our mission
which includes those for instance 155
ammunition which is the the most
commonly used in the in the world in the
Cradle or by the ukrainians we have
increased the guidelines for how much
of this type of emission allies should
have and we are also
strengthen our work to standardize and
to ensure that this full
interchangeability so NATO is addressing
these issues they need to run for
production in many different ways using
existing tools using our our Amanda to
set standards and guidelines and the
Allies are now implementing and
following up and production is
is going up okay Greek TV
then
the lady up there thank you
agency Secretary General you have
mentioned a lot of times that the two
percent on defense spending is the floor
not the ceiling are the Allies closer to
read say more concrete agreement and
more concrete and obligatory agreement
on this two percent on this target thank
you
John says yes we have made good progress
on also agreeing a new defense
investment pledge
where we regard two percent of GDP
um for defense not as a as a ceiling but
at the minimum floor but but as
important as that we are making progress
and close to having all the details in
place for a new investment pledge is the
fact that actually allies have stepped
up so this commitment is not only
demonstrated in words but also in deeds
and the new defense investment figures
we released today for defense
investments in 2023 or encouraging they
are positive their biggest increase in
decades 8.3 percent increased defense
spending across Europe and Canada that
is so in real terms adjusted for
inflation that is something we haven't
seen across NATO for decades and
reflects that NATO allies are taking
this extremely seriously because to
provide support to Ukraine to sign
long-term contracts for defense
production with the defense industry and
to replenish our own stocks between
invest in more a high-end capabilities
there is a need for more money and now
the the extra money is coming in with
the
within total of 450 billion since we
made the difference in defense
investment Fetch and only this year
8.3
increase
so uh so that reflects that this is this
is something which is taken extremely
seriously by allies so of course still
we have a way to go and therefore I
expect further increase next year and
that also
we expected this year 11 allies to meet
the the two percent guideline which is
significantly more than when we made the
guidelines in 2014 that was a decade
pledge that will then run out in or end
in 2024 and so in next year we expect a
significantly substantially more allies
to meet the two percent Target and then
to move on from there when you agree a
new a new pledge
foreign
getting back to support to Ukraine two
questions please
um the first one on the comprehensive
action plan you said the Allies have
pledged 500 million euros is that for
one year
um and uh allies ready to commit to 500
million on a multi-year basis and the
second question on bringing Ukraine
closer to Nato
um what would it mean in Practical terms
if the map requirement were dropped
thank you
um
so we are now finalizing the uh the text
and the and the decisions on both these
issues so therefore I'm a bit careful to
go into the details
you will see all the details on both the
questions you asked within a few days
and I think I will only make my task of
leading the process and to ensure that
we end on a strong and United position
on these issues more difficult if I now
at this press conference went into the
exact
details of the language and the wording
and the and the and the different
Alternatives which are now addressed but
I can say that I'm confident that when
we finalize this uh these consultations
and and have the decisions in place by
the summit uh we will see that there is
a strong commitment NATO allies to
provide a substantial sustained
economic support to Ukraine both as NATO
to the comprehensive assistance package
for the different specific
purposes like Fuel and and different
types of equipment but also for their
multi-air program to ensure that the
Ukraine transition from solidarity to
Nato standards and uh and the doctrines
the full interoperability
um and um and
on the on the membership action plan
well the enemy not go into the details
but the reality is that with all the
different programs we have with the NATO
Ukraine council with with uh with the
multi-air program for interoperability
we will move Ukraine closer to Nato and
uh and uh and that will help us to also
move on the issue of of sending a poster
message also on the membership question
the answer
thank you for the opportunity
Mr Secretary General we have been
hearing lately warring signals both from
Russia and Ukraine on possible
provocations nuclear plant
um would a Chernobyl type accident with
the radioactive clouds impacting NATO
country be considered a possible trigger
for Article 5 has that message been sent
to Moscow
I think that first of all I think it is
important to understand that Wars are by
Nature dangerous and also unpredictable
and of course we are monitoring and
following very closely
the situation also around we will call
them on the nuclear power plant there
and we also strongly welcome the fact
that
that the international atomic energy
agency is is monitoring closely they
have their experts
following the following situation and
this is important because
separitza power plant is Europe's
largest nuclear power plant
um the national atomic energy agency
have a responsibility they have a
mandate we support that when it comes to
ensure that
relations and safety standards are fully
upheld that is of course a big challenge
in the war zone and therefore Russia has
a particular responsibility
the best and the message from NATO and
from
the iaea is that Russia should not
launch any attacks from the power plant
they should not of course attack the
power plant and they should withdraw
their forces that will enable
the the experts to do their work in a
better way and they have had access and
have made some judgments and some
assessments
um they have said that they have seen no
visible indicational minds or explosives
at this stage but I've also asked for
additional access to verify the safety
of the plants so we continue to call on
Russia to withdraw from the facility and
ensure the Ukrainian and international
experts have full access we continue to
monitor the international atomic energy
agency continue to Monitor and and we
call it Russia to withdraw its washes
Ukrainian use agency
of Ukraine thank you for the call I just
want to adjust will security guarantees
for a future in agenda of Indian Summit
and if I may about the future membership
uh both Ukraine and NATO members agreed
that the issue of membership could be
considered after the war is over would
not it be an incentive for Russia to
continue this war endlessly and don't
you think that the best guarantee
security guarantee for Ukraine is to
ensure the NATO membership thank you
the most important thing now is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails and that
President Putin Russia do not win this
war and uh and and therefore the most
burgeon task is the Military Support to
Ukraine
uh also knowing that the more land
Ukraine is able to liberate and the
stronger their hand will be eventually
be at the negotiating table uh with uh
to find a peaceful enduring and just uh
end to this war when the war ends then
it is important of course that we have
the Frameworks in place to ensure that
Russia President Putin not only rests
its forces
retrain them reallocate them rearm them
and then re-attack at the later stage
that is actually a lasting and an
enduring piece and to ensure that we
need Frameworks in place to provide
Ukraine with what they need to ensure
that Russia is not going to attack again
and that's exactly what allies are
discussing the part that's part of the
discussion on the membership issue
within NATO
um
um and as I said I'm confident that I
will find the United Way Forward as NATO
allies
on on Ukraine's request for membership
we will also I expect make some concrete
decisions on interoperability and all
the things that will help you're going
to move closer to Nato then it is also
publicly known and has been announced by
by several hours that they are bilateral
multilateral consultations with Ukraine
on different types of security
arrangements
and I welcome also those efforts
we have been briefed about them and and
it will adjust a complement and underpin
the efforts of NATO answer as the
alliance
um the message is of course that that we
take our decisions are several
independent nations together with
Ukraine so it's not for Russia to make
any decisions to have any veto and again
we help Ukraine to win this war by
providing military support and we'll
continue to do that
okay Reuters
Andrew Gray from Reuters um Secretary
General could you tell us some more
about the NATO Ukraine Council and
perhaps put it in concrete terms for an
ordinary citizen who doesn't follow this
stuff super closely and in particular
what kind of powers might it have would
Ukraine be able to convene a meeting if
it wants to do that and could it be a
forum for sharing intelligence for
example
yeah
the NATO Ukraine Council will be a
council which is then formed by the 31
NATO allies hopefully through 32 allies
with Sweden but now 31 NATO allies and
Ukraine and we will be together as
together the council as equals uh and it
uh we will agree what we call modalities
on how and and how often this this
Council will meet uh but I expect that
we will agree modalities that also then
uh uh ensures that uh individual members
of the council and that includes also of
course Ukraine can call a meeting uh to
uh have what you call crisis
consultations uh that is if they felt
feel threatened in a way and they or
they see any need for Urgent
consultations then they can they can
invoke this crisis consultation
mechanism between
the NATO allies and the train as the
members of of the council then then the
council can also make decisions and this
is fundamentally for the council to
decide what decisions they can make uh
but this uh this opens up for a more
practical joint activities is it opens
also for establishing subcommittees to
address specific tasks issues be it
cyber a bit I don't know uh
interoperability or there are the that's
all for the to to the council to uh to
uh to design
um and for instance a work program so
the whole idea is that by establishing
it we establish a body where we actually
do things together decides things
together consult together on issues that
matters for our security
and uh and and that brings again Ukraine
also to Nato and it provides Ukraine and
all of us with a tool that we can use to
do more together and strengthen
the cooperation and the ties between
Ukraine and all the NATO allies so this
will bring Ukraine closer to Nato it
will be good for I'm good for NATO and
the inaugural meeting will be next week
in real news
Germany has already said that they are
opposing the cluster bonds to Ukraine we
understand that they could help Ukraine
Advance with their offensive uh but if
the U.S indeed decides to send them is
there another risk that we could see
first cracks in NATO's Unity with
regards to that topic thinking
it is for individual allies to make
decisions on what type of weapons all
allies agree that we should deliver
weapons
ammunition to Ukraine and allies are
delivering an unprecedented level of
Military Support Ukraine for German I
mean there are many other allies
are delivering different types of
ammunition weapons to Ukraine but when
it comes to Cluster ammunition there's a
difference between ours because some
allies have signed the convention on
plus dominations and they don't have a
customization so of course there is no
class missions to provide to Ukraine all
their allies have not signed their
convention
and many of them at least some of them
have custom initials so it is for these
individual allies and to make those
decisions
um Nate class the alliance doesn't have
a a position on the convention simply
because there are different views among
allies on the convention and also of the
uh the in any possession of of clustered
ammunitions
um
custom nations are only used
in the war in Ukraine
um by both sides
the difference is that Russia is using
customization to attack to invade
Ukraine
Ukraine is using close definition to
protect itself against an aggressor
[Music]
regardless of whether they have signed
the
conventional impersonation agree that we
should provide Military Support to
Ukraine as we do also generally but
exactly what the type of weapons what
type of munition varies between allies
and will continue to very vaginals
okay I think we have one last question
from Trojan TV
just
Georgian TV
can we expect some kind of messages in
videos regarding transparent countries
from Georgia for example thank you
well uh our message has been for a long
time and was reiterated at the at the
previous Summit that we need to
strengthen our partnership
with uh partners that are vulnerable for
Russian uh interference and and pressure
and at the summit allies
with Retreat our support to the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
Georgia within its International
recognized borders
um allies will also I expect
reaffirm Jordan's right to decide its
own future and foreign policy free from
outside intervention
therefore we call on Russia to withdraw
its forces
it has in Georgia without any consent
from the Georgian government and to end
its recognition and manifestational of
course and the South osce
and I think also we have to
uh to recognize once again the
importance that Georgia plays and also
strengthening the partnership between
NATO and Georgia and the commitment to
euro-atlantic security so
um so we we are we will
address also other partners than Ukraine
of course Ukraine will be at the top of
the agenda because it's a full-fledged
War
taking place in Ukraine but we'll also
address the importance of strengthening
our our partnership with uh with a
country like George
thank you very much
sorry follow up on Council on the
council
in a one last follow-up thank you
thank you thank you so much just follow
up on uh NATO Ukraine Council in the
past Hungarian constantly we are
blocking uh NATO Ukraine commission do
you think that Hungarian again or other
allies will have a right to block such
meetings and do you think it's really
fair upgrade for ukrainians to have a
council while NATO Russia Council still
exists so first of all the fact that we
establish the native Ukraine Council
demonstrates that all allies also
Ukraine and also sorry also Hungary is
in favor of that because that's the way
we make decisions
second we have
the modalities that will ensure that we
can convene the meeting
and we will of course continue to when
we start to to have meetings in NATO
Ukraine Council and absolute country to
continue the meetings also in the future
thank you very much
thank you